こんにちは、はじめしゃちょ―と
まさき取締役です
はい、皆さま、Ｔシャツアレンジと言うものをご存知でしょうか？
ちょっと、いろいろ調べてみたんですけども
使わなくなったＴシャツとか、皆さん持ってると思います。
持ってないＴシャツ、そのまま捨てるの勿体無い、と言う事で、
使わなくなったＴシャツをアレンジして、別な使い方をしようと言うものが、Ｔシャツアレンジと言う物らいいです。
ほんとにＴシャツアレンジって言っても色んなのがあって、
切ってみてVネックにしてみたり
首元が広めのTシャツにしてみたり、
切れ目を入れて、ちょっと、こう、セクシーにしてみたり
腕の袖をめっちゃ短くしてみたり
も、なんか、タンクトップとかにしてるのもありました。
リメイクしてバックにしてみたり、
クッションカバー？
ま、そう言ったように使わなくなったTシャツをリメイクして、兎に角、他の色んな事に使ってみるってのが、Tシャツリメイクって物で、ございます。
で、今回なんですけども
企画として、我々もTシャツリメイクをしてみようと言う事で
Tシャツリメイク選手権～！
今回アレンジするTシャツは、ポコロンダンジョンズを開発している株式会社グレンジさんから提供していただきました。
こちらのTシャツ、加工しても良い、と言われているので、
今回このTシャツを使ってTシャツアレンジをやって行こうと思います
ここで、もう一つお話があるんですけども
なぜTシャツアレンジをするかと言うと、
我々のTシャツですね
意味深に、お揃いのTシャツを着てみましたが
詳しくは動画の最後にちょっと色々お知らせがあるので是非最後まで見てください。
と言う訳でTシャツアレンジやっていくわけなんですけども、
要するに、あれでしょ？斬新なTシャツアレンジをした人が勝ち、
芸術系だし、まぁ、こちらもまぁ、芸術系なので、なかなかクリエイティブな物が出来るのかなと思ったので
やろう！
無事、Tシャツアレンジ、作り終わりました
僕とまさき、それぞ二つづつ作品を作ったので、それを今から二人づつ交互に紹介して行って
どれが、一番斬新で、クリエイティブティな作品なのかを決めて行きたいと思います。
まず最初はまさきです～・・どうぞ！
テーマは、　‟ワイルドだぜ”
丸く、じゃなくて、Vネックにしたのと、
ここに、切込みを入れて、ワンポイントのワイルドさをアピールした、男性向けのアレンジTシャツですね。
夏とかでも良さそうですよね
うん、そう。これからの熱い時の助けに
下と相まって、バスケっぽい。
バスケっぽいね！
全然アリじゃん
や～アリアリあり！
やぁ、結構けっこう、あり、アリ、あり
どうぞ
どうですか
や！斬新だねぇ。
でしょ？
多分、見てもらったら分かると思うんですけども、
Vネックですね。
あの、サイトにも書いてあったんですよ。
「思い切ってVネックにしましょう」
ああ、確かにね？
思い切ってVネックにしてみました。
男性だけじゃなく、女性にも着てもらいたいと思って、
いつでも授乳ができるように。
こっちからも行けるし、こっちからも、行けるっている・・ツーウェイの授乳方法があるって言う・・・
すごい。なかなかやっぱ
普通のデザイナーが思いつかない
まあ、確かにパッと見でも
では続いては、三作品目。
まさきさんです。どうぞ！
今度は・・
女性向けです
半円形にして
ちょっとセクシーな感じ？
あと、こっち、肩が出るようにしてます
肩でるの？
そう。肩がでる・・・
夏場いますね、そういうの
あのこの辺からも、覗ける肌
いるいる！！そういう女子いる！